only meet the person you're going to
marry when you already believe that it's
time to get married people tend to meet
a person date a person they're like I'll
fall into marriage I'll just I'll sort
of I'll fall in love with them and then
I'll and then I'll decide to get married
wrong you decide you're going to get
married then you meet the person you can
fall in love with because you're
thinking in a different way when you're
when you're dating for marriage you have
a set of values that are that are in
your head what do you want your life to
look like how do you want your life to
be structured what do you want to teach
your kids what kind of community like
these are really important questions
because you're also trying to look
beyond what that 2-year passionate love
period is going to look like to what is
the rest of your life going to look like
and that sets up a whole different
expectation of the person you're dating
and and for yourself right why are you
actually in the room with this person is
it because they're good-looking and
because they're sexy or is it or is it
because this is a person you actually
want to spend serious amounts of time
with and maybe commit to